giá phạm trong nước bất ngờ giá mùa tham sâu theo dễ biến hạn dịch của thị trường thế giới.
Tại nhiêu xe nghiệp kinh dân vàng lớn U.S.C.
Đồ gì? B.S.C.
giá phạm viên S.C. Đồng nghiệm ít ở mức 1 trăm bị chính phải 1 trộ động một lượng
mô vào và 1 trăm 2 mối phải 1 trộ động một lượng
mang ra giá 1 trăm nghìn động một lượng sò với phía liên trước.
Cung thời điểm vàng giãn S.C.C. lại chính chính chính chính được sâu dịch ở mức 1 trăm
mối 1 phải sau đến 1 trăm bị bệnh phải 1 trộ động một lượng
giá mt. Bộ chăm nghìn động mối chiều.
Một số thương yệu khác như đầu gì hương thịn vượng và P.N.C. cũng được trình giá.
Trong đó, bình đầu trình lịch sử dá mua bán tích tục duy tri ở mức cao từ 2 đến 8 trộ động một lượng
từ lợi hình sản phẩm.
Trên thị trường thế giới, giá phạm ra ngày ở mức 3,8 bộ mi tám đô là Mỹ Một House,
giá m건 bẩy đô là Mỹ sò với phíaên sâu dịch trước.
Nguyên nhân trủ yếu xó đồng đô là Mỹ tăng trở lại và hạt động chốt lời của nhà đầu tư sau nhiều phíaên tăng lên tiếp.
Dính biến giá phạm trong nước cho thấy tâm lý tận trọng của Mỹ dân và nhà đầu tư trước các yêu tổ biến động kinh tế tản cầu.
Đông thời cho đợi những đều trình chính xác quán lý thị trường vàng tư phía cơ quan chức năng.
Các chuyên giá phía nhỉ cần theo dõi xói xác biến quốc tế để có quyết định đầu tư phu hợp.